david gross was awarded the nobel prize
in physics in 2004 for his seminal work
in nuclear physics his work has helped
us to understand the universe at the
smallest possible level he uncovered the
curious strong force between quarks the
subatomic particles found in protons
that make up every item found in nature
he's also one of the leading lights of
string theory which is changing the way
we think about space and time professor
grosses research has brought physics
tantalizingly closer to formulating a
grand theory one that attempts to unify
the four fundamental forces found in our
universe and it's these theories that
are now finally being put to the test at
the multibillion-dollar Large Hadron
Collider at CERN this is your chance to
put your questions directly to professor
gross who's happy to answer questions
about everything from the latest results
from the Large Hadron Collider to the
truth behind time machines if you have a
youtube account please visit
nobelprize.org youtube channel click on
view comments and respond to this video
with a text question will preferably
upload a video of your own professor
grouse will answer a selection of your
questions please make sure you upload
your questions no later than the 25th of
jun 2010
and I look forward to receiving and
answering your questions
you